cuéntenos cómo fue el proceso y cuáles
fueron los principales hallazgos
gracias bueno el proceso fue a partir de
una filtración que recibe el diario the
gardian esta filtración es entregada al
consorcio internacional de periodistas
de investigación y a través del
consorcio se reúne un equipo de más de
180 periodistas de 42 medios de todo el
mundo las revelaciones
incluyen la forma agresiva en la que
uber ingresa a la mayoría de los países
haciendo caso omiso a las leyes y muchas
veces como sucedió en la argentina ni
siquiera avisando que iba a empezar a
operar estas filtraciones
involucran aproximadamente 124 mil
archivos que incluyen 83 mil correos
electrónicos cuando se habla de que web
presionó a líderes políticos de qué
manera lo hizo
bueno hay un caso muy concreto que se ve
a través de mensajes de texto es una
serie de conversaciones que se tienen en
octubre de 2015 entre el ceo de de tve y
emanuel macrón que en ese momento era el
ministro de economía en francia en esa
oportunidad había disturbios en la
ciudad de marbella y cuando la
procuraduría regional de marsella decide
suspender el servicio en algunos puntos
de la ciudad los lobbistas de uber
llaman a macro para pedirle ayuda ok
mantengan la calma dice el algo vamos a
poder hacer y efectivamente dos días
después la medida fue revertida y los
integrantes de uber le dicen bueno
muchas gracias por su apoyo pero después
hay otro tipo de comunicaciones que
revelan de la lectura de los correos
electrónicos cosas que a mí
personalmente me llamaron
la atención yo estoy en el consorcio
desde panamá papers para aquí he visto
muchas filtraciones periodísticas pero
nunca había visto una cosa como esta por
ejemplo la jefa de comunicaciones de
uber diciendo somos decididamente
ilegales y por otro lado el ceo de uber
diciendo ok no se preocupen si va a
haber violencia en francia la violencia
garantiza el éxito esto es algo que yo
jamás había visto en comunicaciones por
escrito si era crucial y ahora over dice
que cambió su forma de actuar y que es
una empresa diferente usted que ha
seguido el caso cree que realmente es
así
no lo creo realmente no lo creo de hecho
aunque la justicia argentina ha
dictaminado que no se incumple ninguna
ley y la cuestión de fondo aquí con las
causas judiciales no se ha resuelto y
para el gobierno de la ciudad de buenos
aires
über sigue siendo una empresa ilegal
esto sin contar con que el hecho de que
esta compañía se erradica en muchos
países pero el ser
a avala con convenios de doble
imposición entonces pagan menos
impuestos por ejemplo aquí en argentina
todos los ciudadanos de las empresas
argentinas pagan 35 por ciento de
impuesto a las ganancias sin embargo
como la empresa que controla über a
argentina está en los países bajos y a
su vez la que controla a de los países
bajos están delaware eeuu se le redujo
el impuesto a las ganancias en un 25 por
ciento y es una manera de eludir
impuestos a través de una sofisticada
ingeniería fiscal que eso es lo que
tiene una sofisticada ingeniería fiscal